more than a dozen cities have now broken
temperature records among them Phoenix
Arizona with its 18th consecutive day
above 43 degrees the Salvation Army is
bringing water hats and sunscreen to the
unhoused I cry all the time I like yell
it yell at the heat until I go away you
know
um just now my friend came to check on
me and I was I couldn't stop sweating in
2022 Maricopa County saw 425
heat-related deaths which was a record
the Salvation Army during this latest
Heat Wave has been serving
four or 500 people per day so we're
hoping with those efforts and the the
efforts of other organizations that are
also providing heat relief that will be
able to keep those numbers down this
year on the other side of the country
Miami Florida had its 14th consecutive
day of temperatures reaching over 35
degrees so walking just from the car
over here something that will take us a
few minutes we needed two bottles of
water because it was that hot he told me
hit that take a break and sit down for a
bit is that hot but here there was also
localized flash flooding as a result of
sudden downpours
and still the hottest place on Earth
Death Valley on the California Nevada
border on Sunday temperatures here
reached 53.33 degrees and the
appropriately named Furnace Creek the
hottest temperature on Earth was
recorded at the same spot on July of
56.67 degrees it's hot
um but the uh the scene the scenery is
awesome
climate scientists say this is what
they've been warning about for decades
more intense and longer lasting patterns
of extreme weather due to global warming
and this year the El Nino climate
phenomenon is exacerbating man-made
climate change 2023 looks to be on track
to be the hottest year on Record She
advertancy Al Jazeera